knowing this two by two confusion matrix
is just the beginning
there are many different metrics can be
derived from those basic metrics
in particular many metrics can be
derived by taking ratios of different
numbers from this basic matrix
first let's introduce a set of metrics
that are derived by normalizing some
terms with the ground truth value
either the total population or the
condition positive or the condition
negative
all these metrics are defined by some
conative divided by those normalization
terms
for example accuracy is the ratio from
the sum of true positive
and true negative divided by the total
population
accuracy is the most basic metric that
many people have intuitive understanding
but accuracy is not always the best
measure when the class label are very
imbalanced
if only one percent of the total
population have heart failure
models can be achieved 99 percent
accuracy by simply predicting everyone
would not have heart failure
so it is important to use the
appropriate metric for measuring the
performance of a predictive model
another important metric is true
positive rate or sensitivity or recall
they have different names because the
same metric has been developed by
different communities
and true positive rate equals the true
positive divided by the condition
positive in the ground truth
to explain the intuition let's assume
positive means heart failure
and negative means without heart failure
the intuition of true positive rate is
to measure among all people with heart
failure
what percentage is correctly identified
by the predictive model
a very related metric can be derived
called false negative rate
which equals one minus true positive
rate
the intuition of false negative rate is
among all heart failure patients
what percentage of those patients is
missed by the predicting model
false positive rate is the ratio between
false positive
and the condition negative the intuition
of false positive rate is to measure
among all people without heart failure
what percentage of them is incorrectly
predicted by the model as to of heart
failure
finally true negative rate or
specificity is the number of true
negative divided by the ground truth
condition negative
which also equals one minus false
positive rate
the intuition behind true negative rate
is to find among
all people without heart failure what
percentage of them is correctly
classified as non-heart failure patients
note that accuracy measures the
combination performance of true positive
and true negative while true positive
rate measures the performance
only about true positive and true
negative rate measures the performance
only about true negative
it is often possible to obtain high
performance on a single metric such as
accuracy
while it's difficult to obtain high
performance on all metrics
that's why we often test a predictive
model against multiple metrics
first of all different metrics are
designed for different situations
it is important to choose the proper
metric for your prediction study